like everybody a mute
there we go
flip i think we're live if you and
philip want to start us off
oh we got the we got the thing i didn't
even see the
uh so see this is we're good to go here
in the future where we live that we were
waiting for someone i was literally
sitting here in my office waiting for
someone to go
like that and no one did that oh
gosh and it's probably because i don't
have the twitch stream up that would be
part of my problem right there
philip how you doing flip i'm doing
great
i'm so excited about today this is going
to be awesome this is always one of my
favorite things
on earth absolutely one of the greatest
uh
most uh profound activities
uh we have what do we got here we got
almost 20 how many
you got 300 competitors no we got 20 19
21 competitors here so this is going to
be crazy
it's going to be great and you know it's
a silver lining right because corona
everything's remote people like oh no i
need to cry
but this this event might be even better
with its remote
i i think at least the the for those of
you who joined us over the summer
uh it did make for um a uh
i i i don't know just made it for a much
more special
uh i think again most of us were going
crazy because of having cabin fever uh
but
this uh no i think this uh this is
really special to do it this way
so so twitch uh just so you know and
youtube and
any one in the future watching this on
pre-recorded media whatever you guys are
using
in the future uh flip you want to tell
people what the basic idea is the rules
how it's going to proceed
yes yes i will uh or at least i'll get a
start and then you'll
hopefully fill in for all the stuff that
i forget um
basically the way this is going to work
is that we have a series of uh
questions that will be uh posted
uh all of the competitors will receive
the questions
over the internet and uh via carrier
pigeon for some of the
are more distant competitors uh they
will then
be uh the audience will be able to see
it too on the
live feed screen over here um
they will then respond uh through
a channel that we have here we will talk
about the various
uh answers that are given share them
with the public
then after we get enough answers
or we deem actually i think we can just
do that by some
form of fiat uh we can just call the
whole thing off
um and then it's gonna be up to the
studio twitch audience
to vote on their preferred
answers and we will then use that to
score the participants
right something like that isn't that how
it goes yes and twitch
as you're listening you'll see the
questions you can't participate
uh officially but you can participate
unofficially and if you have
you're welcome to post anything on chat
you want including suggestions or hints
or tips
um and we have a special special feature
for you
twitch people out there today you have a
question
that only you guys can work on and none
of the participants here in the contest
can
that's correct so do you have that
question over there with you
where here's the question twitch yes
make
a magic trick using wolfram language
enjoy do we have any submissions yet
yeah i don't know i'm looking
um i see a bunch of random numbers in
the submission whenever you get that
just post it in twitch chat and uh
we'll eventually see them and we can
talk about them if they're going to any
kind of magic trick any interactive
things could be a web form
could be a dynamic within wolfram
language anything that works for you
that would fool us we'll be we'll be pen
and teller i'm not sure who's who here
yeah i don't know
we're both talking
okay are we ready to go i think we are
um
participants are we ready yes
contestants
yes yep all right
uh so now back to you know jesse
friedman our uh
the the man behind the curtain he is
going to
unleash the first question on to us i do
believe
here it comes here comes
it says i do not think it i do not think
it means what you think it means
see we've already gone crazy create a
depiction of a mole
using any wolfram language visualization
functionality
symbolic graphics graph plotting
equation plotting
please include your submitted solution a
comment
or a text cell describing your mole
all right wait what's a hole i don't
know what is a mole
could be you know i'm gonna go have some
mexican food later too
might have some of that right after i
have this skin tag worked on
over here maybe i don't know how about
you
oh we already have a solution well
that's ridiculous i don't even have time
to drink here i'm trying to
i'm trying to drink i didn't even see
this
okay here we go oh my gosh
well this is okay hold on here we go so
we've we've got a few moles here so
from uh can you can you move your screen
to the uh yeah that's where i'm moving
it right now look at what i'm doing
yeah magic so from so from robert
mendelsohn
we have uh uh this what does wolfram
alpha think a mole
is and uh and it failed uh
on uh it failed in the in the feed but
this is really uh i do believe what he
thought it was
uh supposed to be so there you go there
nice
uh sander has visualized a mole
for us so you know again we've got these
are some um
these are solid well all right
oh yeah when do we start being uh
you know hard crazy judging kind of
people
yeah i don't know we can do that
whenever we'd really like right this is
it's not so much about oh we got wait we
have we have new ones
we have hold on here oh my goodness so
so here's uh we have one from bob here
let me grab this one
all right so here's a mole mole
a mole of moles this uh this did
actually come up
the other day so that's a good one
um that is it delivers what it promises
yes it does
uh and here though from uh from mike
s is if it will
let's see i don't know if i did i get it
oh good so it basically
renders the input yeah it rendered the
input it's okay
i'll grab the whole thing for us here
sorry
but what is it it is it
it it it it's a net chain that has
somehow i don't see his uh explanation
in here
remember everyone uh you're supposed to
add an explanation um
we have we have one here from luigi hold
on here i grab this one
hey guys just jumping in here jesse
actually turned off the question because
we already
got a bunch of submissions yeah if you
want him to turn it back on to get some
more
submissions just let us know oh yeah
this is my command
very easy answer let's turn it on for
one more minute
yeah i i like the idea of trying to grab
one one more here okay
because there are probably some that you
can pretty easily dismiss is you just
don't like them before you say yeah no
no
okay see now hold it okay turn it back
off quick turn it off we're getting a
fire hose
all right so here i do like this one
uh someone has visualized an actual mole
uh using this we've got uh some web
image search moles over here did you see
any of these you want uh
philip that you would like to add arrest
i think that's
matt right definitely that that
qualifies
uh was there an explanation for which oh
for address for matt yeah
uh no no explanation see guys you gotta
follow the
instructions quick can you set your zoom
on the notebook to 150 or 200
i will do that thank you much i usually
have it that way by default because
i am an old man and cannot see things
very well
um so okay let's just go through the
beginning so robert robert's solution
doesn't
does use a visualization it does have a
depiction and does have a comment or
text cell describing his mole
alpha mole that is option number one yes
sander does not have uh visualization or
comment or text cell
yeah sorry davis yes bob does have a
comment or text so
up to you flip you're the visualization
expert yeah i
i i yeah we'll go with that it at least
has
i mean yeah yeah yeah because it's
clever
see it's the visualization is down but
the clever is high
right three so far right yeah yeah okay
mike s does not have a comment or text
so luigi
i added one oh you did okay we'll take a
look at that
second yeah oh you oh you posted it
again okay uh luigi
i don't see it in the second one but
that's okay well we'll see
so luigi's also doesn't have a
description right yeah
um okay uh matt's matt's is
also good but lacking a description yeah
i don't know if we disqualified her
because it's cute i like it
yeah i don't know i think maybe i'd uh
so i mean i like this
you guys can decide whatever you want
yeah if it's a good answer
i say keep it yeah yeah i say keep this
okay
right you could say that wolfram
language code is the description yeah
there you go
maybe you don't need a description after
all uh
uh let's see nick's um this is a mole
yeah and it's a web image search uh yeah
well let's let's okay so we uh it's a
solution
uh here's another visualization here uh
hp 2000. i want to keep this one
all right i'm blown away by total
annihilations i don't understand it
yeah and then this one right here right
another one with uh with the explanation
if you want
okay uh another one so maybe we should
see here's a mole mole as well so this
with a visualization so 1000 definitely
counts
that should be five right i think we do
uh did we miss anybody trained
in net train to predict the image of a
mole you did mike s train to net train
to predict the images what
well you have to send that without the
uh net chain uh
guys because we can't yeah we don't know
what's in that net chain
yeah yeah we can't it sends it as a
raster in this thing oh my god
okay so how many do we have so far are
you keeping a list jesse
is somebody keeping a list for god's
sake who knew there was a mole curve
so uh danielle has supplied us with this
i had no idea that this exists i guess
you can usually just come up with
any put any word and curve after it and
something
exists right and uh flip if you if you
copy over the name
labels from the chat into your notebook
then the list
is in your notebook it's all in one it's
great
you know i try that and then it well you
know it's my cut and paste
see i because that's all i get is the i
don't get the whole thing when i try to
copy and paste
so how many do how do we have five are
we ready to go i think we have five by
the way the mole curve oh i'm sorry
it's a mole like curve so is that a
submission from somebody or is that yes
that is from uh that's from danielle
danielle wins
yeah i don't know so what do we got so
we got we got the
we got the mole curve so this is what
you're going to judge on here
we got the mole curve all right
we've got the mole of of ascii art
right from adrus
we've got the uh
hp 6000 yeah this network that i'm still
not sure
if it really exists or not but i love it
and who is that
who's the network that's address no
that's my
i guess oh i'm sorry that was mike s
yeah sorry that shows you how well that
works
yeah um what else did we have
five right yeah so would is that four we
need one more
i lost count does someone keep in count
what do we have
uh it's hard for us to keep count
two three oh yes and then we have
we have the we have this this guy here
the molecule
so this is a literal interpretation of
the answer from uh hp 2000.
yep so we can we can go with that
good um and uh do we have
carlos on uh what did he call it a skin
something the cow she the cross section
of a skin tag
oh is that one
oh carlo damn it okay yes
sorry here here for our our viewing
audience there's
carlos i think of all of the choices
we're choosing the ones that are not
uh a web image search or from alpha
submission
right yeah probably although this is
still pretty terrifying
again just to know this it even exists
is it
okay is that is the is the vote live do
you guys need it so okay so oh so jesse
would like for us to
label in the notebook if i can yes all
right so
this with total annihilation uh
definitely
is uh let's jesse let's make that number
one
jesse let's make this mole curve number
two
just because it was surprising
this is uh mike's right or with no gosh
amaranth yeah yeah so hold on
that'll be number three i'm i'm going
i'm going to get the
i'm going to get the the label right now
for you
in case we have three we got three this
thing which still
amazes me yeah
and that's that's mike s and then number
five
should be the uh literal answer right
here
perfect and that's who's uh that is
sorry i just scroll past it
so much scrolling that is hp 2000 okay
all right is is the vote live how do we
know if it's live
uh i think i can go here there we go
there we go
so twitch audience
vote away so we've got danielle c
with the with the
with the mole curve we have addressed we
have mike s
in here i'll just so you can just so we
again can
oops so we can uh
so you can see them all right here's
here's hp
2000's mole mole
here's 8 earth's neural network
trained to c moles
here is a dress
dragon art image
and here's danielle's mole curve and
of course the great total annihilation
and his
uh cross-section of a mole
oh there's been some huge changes in the
twitch votes
oh my goodness something is happening
yes look at this so
8 earth 8 earth pulling away with that
outstanding whoop sorry uh aider is
pulling away without that outstanding
answer nice
let's see how much time do we have left
haters
there we go look it's coming down the
timer i don't know i didn't
this is one of those things that we
didn't ask people is how many
seconds just play that awesome welcome
music yeah yeah i got it here somewhere
well which one's eighterth
i don't know because eight earth doesn't
have to say who eight earth is if
vader's doesn't want to say
you mean which submission it was the
ascii art yeah the ascii art sorry
yeah oh i see i thought you were
questioning the existence
of aderath idareth or matt how do you
find i i pronounce it in dareth
oh darius okay okay sorry
it's like you're philip mayhem no
right yeah no there it is oh we have a
winner oh there it is there it is ladies
and gentlemen
the ascii and here's your
here's your chat here's your first
answer
there you go right there there is your
see the leaderboard
yeah so that means
the leaderboard will pop up i swear
all right and we're ready almost for the
second question
yes oh boy yeah i know
so wait we're waiting for the
leaderboard to update itself through the
magic of technology
yet again yet again
oh i see yes three way tie for second
that's gotta break any algorithm yeah no
there's no algorithm that can deal with
that
look at that oh there we go there we go
good job everybody all right jesse kudos
in the studio booth we are ready for
questions
ma'am behind the curtain and here it
comes
i'm trying to find the music to play in
between the questions again so
go ahead you want to you you get started
see can do you get a theme here
i don't know phil yeah so we didn't know
what a mole was we had lots of different
solutions let's talk about ambiguity
this is
the most ambiguous word in the world
your task
contestants is to find the english word
or words
that are the most ambiguous and yes the
question itself is ambiguous
uh please include again in your solution
uh a comment or text cell
describing why yours is yes correct
solutions
again if it is not obvious from the
wolfram language uh
i guess so all right the timer
have you started uh jesse are we doing
is there a timer what's going on there
whatever you want oh okay oh i see so
mine just shows
five minutes i just didn't know what we
were i didn't know whether we had a
we reset a clock there or something
flip what give us a situation in your
life
when somebody close to you a loved one
perhaps has said a word to you that was
ambiguous that has caused you
destruction and confusion for decades
you know
it's funny you mention this i was just i
was out in the backyard and as any good
uh kid who grew up in the 80s i was
humming uh
the smiths to myself uh due to just
abject depression you know that one
experiences as one gets older
and i was thinking about morrissey's
line when he sings that he is the sun
and heir
and to me that was the sun in the sky
and the air that one breathes and but
he's singing as the sun as the
descendant and heir as in yeah so that
literally yesterday i was singing i am
the son
and yeah oh my goodness well guess what
we already have two solutions yeah we do
so here we go sorry here jesse i
i will take your unbridled jesse advice
as one that's the only kind i offer yeah
i know you that's
that's what we all love here so robert
mendelsohn
has given us the word data love
speaking of speaking of ambiguous words
uh
and so you've got the word data for love
um medicine was first last time too wow
he's
quick yeah yeah yeah so he's you know um
here's uh
he's just claiming by fiat that love has
the most definition
true that is pretty yeah you know i
would like to see a
empirical uh validation of all of those
perhaps the word that has the most
definitions
i don't know might perhaps that's the
next one look at this repository
look look yes
mr repository himself let's see your
repository goes to the repository he
does
he does that to add a little flair
that's our friend bernardo bernardo
yeah bernardo i love bernardo
that's that's a great solution so it's
so what it
you're you were looking for the longest
oh yeah so basically the longest
definition
so the most definitions there you go
oops there's probably ties but
i just took yeah oh well then i'm sorry
we're gonna disqualify
disregard it yes um here's nick
martin who uh let's see here words that
contain
all letters of the word ambiguous and by
the way
bigamous how about that for a uh
interesting one
yeah yeah i would not have thought of
that i like that so i think we have two
so far
yeah no three right but the first one is
oh okay oh i see what you're saying yes
oh two that we would like yes
so the number so number one we're going
to give a good old bob repository we're
gonna
we're gonna throw him in at number one
yep uh
uh nick very nice you're very nice
um here it is okay another one here you
want uh you want the one from hank here
let's see what we get
my apologies my it's the text
i need to make this text bigger because
everything is about
uh oh i see
that's cute yes right uh so
using the ambiguity ambiguity function
so that's clever
that's a little bit of language goodness
that's cute um
what else we got oh uh okay so total
annihilation total annihilation has
brought us
number four nope
someday i'll get this copy paste thing
worked out
it's i understand that it's a technology
that we have uh
uh this takes forever but gives the
right answer
by the way it finished evaluating if you
reopen i'll send the
thing okay oh that's beautiful you did
so this is great so you're using word
data
mapped across word data and looking at
the oh that's
yeah this will be insane the result why
do you need the star why not just word
data open bracket close bracket
does that do all words yeah right
that comes out first is break oh that's
great
okay so 76. did you guys not get oh
maybe i didn't oh my god wait a minute
something just sent
i just got a let's close jesse let's see
yeah jesse
close it down shut it down hold it down
those we're getting the firehose of
answers
all right you know i should also use
jesse who writes excellent tools
everybody he has the find next solution
uh fine previous solution buttons that i
never use
when i'm doing that which i you know he
goes through all that work to make
things
useful um mike s
has brought us oh yeah break so break is
th
and and so who do you have now do you
have a break is the first in
alphabetical order
yes okay the most yeah okay
how many six uh so which one do you see
any others in here you want to do
i like this i like this one from uh i
like this one from uh
what is this vindobona this is
some
um kata
as a massive
let's check this one out here hold on
i don't know do you see anything there
that you that you particularly like
no the rest of them seem fine uh so uh
is that five do we have yeah i think we
have five so what do we got here so we
have a number you guys don't have to
just give it to the first five that
submits
no no we're we're trying to be good but
we're taking them in order that they are
submitted right yeah
so uh number one will be bob repository
number two uh uh nick's
clever solution here number three
akan you like this we going with this
it uses ambiguity function which is yeah
i love that that uses that so
and sadly we have to you know exactly
yes right this is what frustrates me
with
carlos we got we always he always
submits something that we have
seems like we have to use because how
dare he
and the last one is mike s right yeah
mike s right
has this terrible strategy of just
submitting good answers quickly
yeah they're expecting them to be
treated fairly
so jesse jesse bring us to the
twitch poll here we go who has the best
answer so does bob repository
jesse you want to have to type all of
the word repository so you're just bob
from here on out i think
usually yes nick if they get it
backwards it'll be fine
all right let's see here yeah oh that's
that is going fast yeah it really is
oops sorry
sorry nick yes
i'm loving so far all i can say
is that i'm loving that now i do feel
like though that while we're waiting
it is time it is time
well i didn't want to cover the voting
see i mean i could go
what what you mean some i should do
something like this yeah
yeah i am thinking hard
see carlo doing this that means i am
thinking hard
i want i'm going to go grab some roids
later just before the thing is that the
timer countdown look at that yeah it is
weird
the timer is counting down quick
everyone so we've got close
oh it's a tie oh any vote can make your
vote mom if you're watching mom just
vote for the one that you like the
oh best he's close
quick i'm protesting
it's all over it's all over
oh that's a crime yeah
if you if you throw your uh penalty flag
you're gonna throw your uh
your your flag for an appeal on that i
think that's the uh
we're gonna have to do var uh let's see
the leaderboard
all right let's see leaderboard
leaderboard oh my gosh
carlo moves ablation arlo what do you
have to say for yourself your code that
was objectively worse than two of the
other submissions
he's appealing he's pandering to the
twitch audience that's right
bernardo bernardo is pandering
i just wanted to say that for me it's
midnight 30.
so remember this isn't a code review
this is a popularity contest
carlo you need all the excuses you can
get next you know bernardo gets to vote
yeah for all of us for any of you out
there who have worked in industry where
someone has said this is not a
popularity contest this is a code review
scott has just given us the very
important transposition
this is a popularity contest jesse let's
go for three
yeah jesse make it happen buddy
30 for 30. oh yeah
okay welcome back so ambiguous right
welcome back to the ambiguity center
here at it's not sports center it's
ambiguity center
generate 30 using cellular automaton
rule
30. go go go go
30 for 30. yes i'm very excited about
this one
i did it i was thinking about the
different ways i mean
so when we when we were looking at these
questions earlier uh uh philip the
the solutions to this one i think you
you had a couple of good ideas on this
one
that oh my god we already have one but
it's not from mendelssohn what happened
yeah no no mendelson did yeah he did
he did mendelson you mad man all right
can you
yeah i'm gonna here i'm gonna bring it
up it's coming up hold on got you know
this is
like i'm running a space center over
here uh you know
the thing with the rocks i hope you have
a lot of service credits
yeah that's actually a good point you
know now that uh
so swede used to be my in on service
credits so we'll see here
so let's what what what is our goal here
you're going to go
so there's this shell of some nautical
creature that produces rule 30. so this
gets through oh yeah
right right right right yes it does oh
my god
and by the way there's a bug i i'm using
21 and there are a couple of these uh
things that have or 12 uh two i mean and
this is happening that's
awesome that is really cool thank you
yes
man that one's really great what the
hell is this this is a neuron sitting on
a cloud
i i don't i don't is that 30 though is
that 30.
did he generate well yeah it like i said
it could be a bug
yeah right 30 items beautiful yes number
one
it's supposed to be 30 items but my
because my credits are weird
yeah so that's number one definitely
here
with 30 shells mike s brings us number
two
or mike's he's just plural there's more
than one
check this out you run blind
blow yeah my mind
that's great let's break this down for
people so so check this out so this is
going to do rule 30
right right he's going to do that i make
my students do this all the time right
and so it just so happens that if you if
you run
rule 30 nine times and you add it up
ah that is there we ah go
i think we have enough jesse we should
probably shut it down yeah
is that right yeah oh yeah let's say one
more minute
one more minute okay yeah why not um all
right so who's next
uh let's see here we got danielle's oh
damn yeah we have dan next
oh we'll from alpha i think we should
well yeah but
yeah no no no we're still okay so will
from alphas i don't think
or web image search is by themselves
we'll probably just disqualify
yeah so uh uh vindo this is
so this is another uh this is a similar
one
only uh you know right nixon and
subtracted one i like it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah good good good so it's it's similar
to
but you know the other one was before
right yeah it's number three here's
luigi
no i swear
from digits well you know it's me and my
my copy paste fingers what yeah so
there's luigi so from digits
so this is going to run it out twice the
basic idea except for the plus five
yeah that's right
yeah right right and he's taken so
basically he's taking the last
uh the last row and then yeah but then
you gotta add five
i know most of it is good plus five okay
who's next
yeah icon coming at you
i'm gonna have to have a talk with some
user interface people about my
inability to copy and paste these how
many three right now right
yes three there's okay
um um why is it still closed
uh jesse did that one minute expire is
that what happened
no i closed it before you changed your
minds back
let's reopen it for uh 15 seconds how's
that sound yeah
15 seconds of sweetness
sweetness a couple people are asking
okay uh and what's the
so this is hacans um
i i wouldn't yeah it's in the top five
yeah okay the right approach is
definitely the right thing to stop yeah
oh my gosh we got a couple of good ones
here okay all right here we go
there's all right so we've got here's a
oh oh
bob mr repository has given us a dynamic
there's nothing i like better well other
than being able to
rain plots 30 geographics
pattern filling 30 uh okay uh i think
okay this is why is it not working
click on the top row of any of them oh
there we go
oh beautiful
so he's made 30 steps okay
yeah yeah this is a make your own 30.
yeah yeah i have to do my own i like
this one from there gotta go for the
vertical squirrel championship
so check this one out from um from nick
here
well jeez nothing better than a solid
copy and paste catastrophe
hold on logo qr code yeah
right that counts definitely yeah that
definitely counts
that number four i think that is number
four right
uh and who else is that this this one
that uh
uh is this is it kailayak or just kyle
i can't you know my kyle af
yeah so this
so integer digits so using that as the
seed
is that the it kind of uh it's similar i
guess to
to let's go with the earlier one because
it came in earlier yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh so do we have five
i think we do that's review
yeah mendelson is one yeah mendelbaum uh
mike s mike s because he came in with
the first clever one on that
yes um uh
this was the other this was a similar
one minus one right
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay yeah uh and the
plus five
no um yeah this one no uh uh well hackon
came in before
right that's but the map one should come
in that's that's
uh creative yes whose map is that hp
2000
that's number four i think right
yeah it's either it i thought or bob and
uh
the resource function definitely is a
winner for me
i don't know yeah is that five then
justin is that five yeah is that jesse
what do we got there buddy
sorry sorry we're just making everyone's
jesse's life
you know that's what we live for is to
you have enough for the pole is that
running
let's see here so we got so
bob mendelsohn oh repeat the five so can
we go through me again yeah yeah yeah
so bob mendelsohn number one right
this uh this clever one by mike's the
plural
of mike yep um
that's two then we we decided to not do
any of those
this was three hp 2000. hp
2000 is three the dynamic
because it uses dynamic and you gotta
scroll forever so
this i i found that one nice and then
the resource function okay so bob and
nick merzin
yeah those are the five letter rip oh
right
yeah yeah let's do it there it is there
we go
nice
i'm just going to get this on repeat and
make it my ringtone
i want some lyrics yeah
this is going and we're cody now
maybe i think it's time for
perhaps some uh you know norwegian death
metal some cookie monster vocals on top
of that
so what do we got happening here so can
i um
can i show my suggested answer yeah
please do yeah yeah
all right let me put that in that
separate thing so i can share my screen
right
yeah there's we're still voting back
there oh i can't
share while you're sharing well here
i've stopped sharing what
yeah it's a magic there's technology
all right how does this look can you see
this
blow it up blow it up yeah this is
phillip yourself you're sending us your
credit card information yeah that's how
we do it here that's how we do
everything
uh so this is a you know let's if you
rearrange them up and bottom it makes it
three x's
text recognize it as xxx
natural this is what we're looking for
people this is what we're looking for
come on all right you can share again
yeah
i just love the text recognized i i was
half convinced somebody went in to
you know well we're just going to go in
and hack a little bit and text recognize
and
make that thing work look at this neck
and neck
oh my goodness i'm loving it i'm loving
it
so the image search versus
the crazy cellular automata it's about
almost over
he was first first first and now he's
first now
he's first yeah yeah all right
let's lead her board it all right here's
the leaderboard
wait for jesse to update the leaderboard
it's coming it's coming
and then we're ready for q4 man
hp 2000 look at this the top two
yes both have zeros so if you've had a
zero so far it means nothing
yes it it does mean nothing
very nice might be the most consistent
points in every and every question the
only one
with points in every question yeah oh
wait oh no
jesse just jesse there was there was a
data entry error and
but still total annihilation we have a
tie for first
so mike's bringing robert m
it's time for second yes
i'm comfortable in the second place
all right let's see uh let's go for q4
q4
give us three sq4
ah
i know i'm just playing the music but
you know because i kind of want the
i'm waiting for the question to come up
said it is your alarm clock said it is
your ringtone you got it
yeah yeah here it is here it is there it
is
it's rendering why wwwd
what would wolfram do
write a function that will give the user
advice on any
yes no question that is based on both
geolocation
and current time where are you and what
time is it
what should i do now i would like to
point out it is
always five o'clock somewhere
and that that's a pretty simple you know
solution
just to give some hints just moving
forward so again
say it one more time all right this is
question number four
write a function gives the user advice
so we're looking at like a magic eight
ball
tarot it could be some kind of playing
card
kind of thing anything any you name it
it could be whatever you
what whatever you think would be you
know using can i share some behind the
scenes
hit me deviations this is your idea yeah
you wanted to manufacture and sell www
bracelets yes i did
yes i think that's a brilliant idea yeah
i think it's oh my gosh
wait a minute wait a minute oh we
already have some solutions
we have okay some solutions
yeah we have solutions yes a ball
just says i by the way i would also like
to
suggest that people who are of a certain
age
uh uh that uh putty from seinfeld would
give you some useful
stuff so this is so total annihilation
has given us the geolocation and now
so he's basically hashing to see if
if the hash is even or not that's so
brilliant
yeah it's so so smart and so compact
yes that is exactly yeah i think we're
done
not to mention cryptographically secure
that's what everyone's looking for their
magic 8-ball yeah yeah
yes no answer but it's a crypto music
all i have to do is wander out into the
backyard and i can test this
in five minutes how about that fantastic
all right so here's a hit well look
here's another one
another use of hash oh my goodness look
at so
so fjra just milliseconds behind
gave us almost exactly the same answer
uh let's see here the mic four solutions
let's do one or
one or two more minutes jesse your
choice surprise us so there's mike's
mike's uh wait so mike's just said that
wow he had this
fgra same solution but yeah right i love
it i love the fact that
so so by the way uh perhaps you know
i'm gonna have to say total annihilation
is a little more elegant
yeah i agree sorry fj already yeah yeah
oh it was milliseconds too yeah yeah
yeah
yeah but you know what we'll cut we'll
send you i'll send you a bottle of coke
yeah if total annihilation wins all
right so what do we have for mike's
so the mics have brought us let's see
here
a little bigger echo go all in uh so
it's just
it's just a it's a visualization
so you know oh sander by the way a
previous
runner-up finally we're getting some
sanders giving us some uh
let's see here i got some nice stuff
here
so mike's answer is always yes yeah
right okay
but but prettier yes
whereas sanders is
again seeding the random generator with
here and now
i think that's a great strategy and then
grabbing a playing card
a random playing card and then grabbing
a random
yes no so i love it
so that's good that's sander definitely
uh
that's sander for number two yeah
excellent all right who's next
uh now we have not enough service
credits available
hey would someone go back there and kick
the machine for me so that i can uh
let's see what happens here the secret
plot is to bankrupt you flip yeah
i think it is we got it
oh no imagery style air um
so so this is this i like this one
so this is mendelsohn here can you could
you send a picture
of your output so that uh or did you
lose all of your credits too hang on but
it's so it's getting starry night that's
fine
yeah uh but the actual answer is just a
table of random words it's unclear if
those are going to be it makes like a
fake motivational poster for you with
some
random piece of advice but it sort of it
sort of
morphs from your question into the
random piece of advice
so you can even type a general question
okay yeah yeah
you can give it any question it'll morph
into some random answer with some
picture behind it
so so see here's the thing uh if i if i
would have had enough service credits uh
uh i
would go ahead and run this but you know
we put we'll put
we'll put mendelssohn on as a definite
maybe yeah yeah definite maybe
um uh aidarith is just giving us some
magic eight ball that's a nice again
using the geo location
uh yeah i think this counts because it's
an extension of the earlier one it's
just as
uh uses the same idea oh my god mod
eight also
i like it oh yeah yeah jesse i think we
got to close it down
jesse you got like three more three
seconds we got four
so let's see here so who's is there any
others
uh captain repository has brought us one
and which of course i don't understand
because i can't
it just is an image it's rendered good
until
yeah i didn't hit the check box i'll
resend it okay
okay let's look at that and yeah
i i can't resend it because it's closed
yeah it's closed okay
but so i can see what it is it's it's
it's brilliant
so so so should i invest in zm
daniel martin is going to give us a it
it it just gives us i i'm worried yeah
we have to skip it because the t
equals down p equals here they don't
they're not used anywhere yeah
yeah yeah yeah skip that one but okay
it's a good idea
uh that's interactive okay yes vinda
bono
yeah this that's the this next one which
if you're on here
if you can uh unmute yourself and say
how to pronounce your name would be
eternally grateful
yes uh if
if here and now you're here now
otherwise goodbye
i don't know how well that will work
okay and then finally we got one from
nick here too right nick let's see that
one
modern universities here because they
value now is less than zero
yeah yeah yeah i like this just because
of the craziness here
so that's five yeah right so you're
getting seconds
and then getting the mean of the first
number uh the mean of oh first of
everything at
your current location oh yeah i'm loving
that so right
now okay so here's our five yep total
annihilation
yeah sander robert mentioned a chance to
rasterize but you got to give it a
chance
and show it during the vote show it
during the vote yeah
those are the five and we'll talk about
yours uh repository bob
yeah there bob bob sent his in the in
the yeah we see it in rocket chat so
yeah here so
yeah sander robert mendelsohn adarith
and nick merzin yes vote twitch whoa
vote twitter sander
and mendelson going at it with aderath
and total annihilation
bringing up the rear because he's just
already asleep
let's talk about the two other solutions
we have here one from uh
from repository bob and one from
aardvark stupid aardvark on twitch has a
good one too
um so can you send me that i don't have
the twitch one there
uh sorry not on twitch on rocketchat i'm
sorry no on twitch i'll just tell you
what it is it's uh i'll
i'll post it in rocketchat okay i'm uh i
like bob's
is basically asking the wikipedia
article on baseball your question
using fine textural answer and there's
text translation
so i'm using your geolocation this is
biggest
so that's good so i only get yeah so so
hold on here let's see
your neural net failed to yeah it did
it's as
is you know classic again i i'm i'm
running the
i got a beta uh run error you know
let's see here that's the same one
yeah no but i'm running it in um i'm
running it in uh
12-1 will it run in 12-1 i'll bet it
will
look at this sander sander pulling away
thank goodness for sander i'm so good so
welcome back sandra we're all we're all
happy to see you here
oh and the the rocky chat one flip if
you see it it's uh
what should i do given a place and time
oh yeah there we go
spring based on the string length it
will tell you what to eat
very specific function oh so i don't
have the translate service
that's that's my current problem uh you
know but you know when your
decision expires at least yeah at least
i know that
so that's good so it's good until it
worked it just it translated it into
your location your language for where
you are yeah oh i see
yes it's right it did that's right
by the way the one that doesn't the poll
is over the pole the polls over
hey wait a minute wait a minute
i just like that marco's got his finger
just working and checking see what's
good good job and robert coming in
second
going to keep us big here
what do we got what's the board oh that
is the one right
annihilation and robert m time oh my
goodness
this is tight so um here's the question
do we do we have to
so that uh we are supposed i just saw
oh seven so so that uh yeah we have time
yeah okay i'm sorry let's go to question
five
jesse unleash the kraken
ah okay hit us it's phenomenal look how
close these are
yeah these are great all right question
five go ahead there
philip tell us all this is the flip
phillips question
yeah go if we find the settings optical
generate
an optical illusion or replicate or
replicate
yeah if you make a new one fine if you
can replicate a famous one that's also
great there's a bunch of links for you
to search
for various illusions including on wool
from alpha
you got it wait a minute what just
happened here
this is my favorite one philip you're
gonna love this one
my daughter something like that yeah
this seems so
very familiar oh my goodness yeah
so that was actually robert that was the
inspiration for the magic trick for the
twitch
uh people so if you could pull that up
flip that's again i will
i will robert you can submit another one
for the optical illusion
uh because that's a uh that would be a
magic trick one yeah very good
right so that's actually one of the
sample answers for the magic question
yes so by the way twitch universe you
still have time
to work on your magic trick let's do
this
do it to them yeah all right okay so
what i want you guys to do is look at
these five cards here
and think of pick one of them all right
and concentrate on it and i'm gonna
click on the
it's gone button you ready and i'm gonna
make your card disappear
one two three
your card is gone your card is gone
this is why i have trust issues
they're gone for me
there you go you ready concentrate
concentrate yeah it's gone
yeah this is a big hint right here
everybody that's that that'll help you
figure out how that trick works
but that is a good one oh look oh nice
oh my gosh
my card was still there because i chose
the 25.
there's one card that stays that's right
yeah
yeah i chose the 25. that's always a
good plan
25 is always there that's right this one
this one's broken isn't it yeah
good um i think we have one
two threes we have three solutions let's
do two more minutes
all right yeah so there's
address mike one of the mic
here's the other mic yeah this one by
the way
right that was beautiful this one we can
talk about
all day long now this is a good question
whether you this is a
say check this out right these are these
classic
illusions based on your based on
receptive fields basically and how they
uh how that how your receptive fields oh
it takes a little while to render on my
side
that's my guess right yeah that's mike s
that one's really nice
although it's i'm formatting you don't
have to re-run it because oh
because you can even change the grade
level yeah i i did and then i
i hit so i hit something you know this
this happens sometimes
how do you type all this so fast yeah
that's what i mime
i have questions i'm just kidding
incredible that's really beautiful i
have beach bald here i might need you to
uh phillip can you support it because we
get the idea
yeah yeah no i'm oh trust me i'm trying
to abort it
uh i might need you to take the con
phillip sure i'm ready all right
uh okay i think you have to stop sharing
i'm going to
yeah even zoom was beach balling for him
yeah it was okay all right here we go
uh so we have so far
uh dereth and mike s and we should close
the question down because we have a lot
of yeah yeah we got a ton of them here
um where uh okay so the next one is uh
mr repository
i'm gonna let you take it from here on
out mainly
they call me mr repository
okay this is a very confusing one here
we go
okay you gotta rejoin the champion mouse
over there's more than their peers
okay mandala
and then it's uh scary bomb nice yeah
i'm scared
man that are that's flip you're the
expert on visual effects which is this
an optical illusion uh
it's uh it's just it's just it's did you
read that did you read the caption
it's clever but there's a caveat then
appears yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah uh we'll put that in the
definite maybes
yeah yeah next
is nick merzin uh
i'm about to see if i can rejoin
everything
yes good i do okay okay
this is one of my personal favorites
right here
let's try this oh yeah
so yeah every ever well everyone think
so
it's a rotating thing but everyone that
all of those circles are traveling in a
straight line
that's beautiful yeah oh the lines are
there yeah excellent one
right and so it's that's the thing
that's so beautiful about that one
is that you even with the lines there
it's hard to see the circles that's
traveling in a straight line
so even with the forced look at that
line it's right there
that's excellent okay that's number
three
here comes sander
that's a classic right through this one
what's the illusion
so these are they well i don't know
about for you but for me
they are this thing is moving like crazy
it's throbbing does it throb for you no
do i need to get it well some people
it's it turns out that these
illusions so these are color edge based
illusions
um and so they basically this is a
uh the i don't know that people on
twitch can kind of respond but
this one definitely definitely like
vibrates uh visually in terms of the
it it shimmers and ripples and it has it
has to do basically with all of those
uh the orientations of all those edges
interesting
uh and this was by sander okay
uh we have web image search those are
great but
i think we'll tend to disqualify web
image searches right
yeah now we have
been afford the service credit stuff
phil
yeah see that's the problem yeah there
we go
this is a classic snake illusion
now i'm i'm gonna guess you didn't
project yeah this is okay in my opinion
yeah yeah so the snake illusion
is is is a or this one this one actually
among
us vision science nerd people this was
this
this was not well explained right away
but
yeah this is this is a really nice one
okay but
pulled from wolfram demonstrations right
all right this next one comes with
instructions
here comes and this is the last entry
this is by oh yeah
yeah yeah okay so what are the
instructions look at the image while
moving your head up and down
yeah this is a this is a
what's happening here well depends if
you have a
well-calibrated monitor you'll actually
start to see
your butt no an ass no a donkey
you'll see a donkey i see a donkey
yeah is that because i moved my head if
i move it left and right do i stop
seeing it
yeah now it you just have to move your
head i believe that's
the uh uh yes you start to see the
nodding donkey
is the right and i think we have all of
us can see a nodding donkey
yes that's us you get it
you get it it's us that are the nodding
jackasons
all right so this one
i don't even think we vote this one just
because we were insulted by
no this one wins guaranteed win right
here's our five uh attireth mike
s nick merzin yes robert mendelssohn and
kyle
af so kyle af is the is the donkey
yeah mendelssohn with this uh we call it
the snake illusion is that yeah
yeah yeah nick merzin with the uh
uh this thing that works for some people
what do you call it color
color yeah it's a color edge
color edge okay it's it's similar to the
snake thing and oh that wait that this
is nick morrison sorry that's sanders
yeah sander did that one yeah and nick
merzin with the lines
this is my favorite too all right paul
is live
hit it hit the poll
show us the poll and uh
i will say to back one of you up the
colored circles
are just sitting there for me though the
sander ones well like i said it it
not everybody right it's not a it it
some people do not and the same thing
with the snakes
some people the snakes don't move either
oh and just to remind people because i
mean i put go ahead the pole is up you
can put the pole up phillip
the oh yeah uh why can't i
paste i wanted to paste mike s's can we
go back to your screen share where you
headed up
um no because mine i lost the
chat log from everybody
sanders actually not in the poll because
i think you miss labeled them in your uh
message
oh well here you know what i can share
that hold on here we go
yeah it's okay wait which one was sandra
we can we can always just cancel this
poll and have her cancel it blow it up
blow it up blow that pole resistance
i did do that wrong i'm sorry uh so uh
all right let's let me copy this over to
yeah you do it one more time and then i
can share the
poll screen okay great so we have
this copy there we go and hopefully i
will ha i will be back in the universe
by the time the uh this is by mike s
okay
new poll new poll please new poll yeah
number one is mike
s number two
is uh a dareth and i don't mean these
numbers in any order but
just so people know this is a dereth i
hope i'm pronouncing it right
matt uh that's number two um
right dereth and uh
mike s yes and then we have
uh kyle af
uh my last name's leigh the goal is to
put the
front and back of my name together
what's your last name leaf
oh kyle leaf i guess yeah see that's
crazy yeah
that's clever too everyone should number
three
sander number four and uh nick merzin
number five
number five yes so now if you want i can
show the poll once the poll is back
up here so the people yes all right
share mine oh you need to unshare
yes uh sunny
sunny unshare get it no no
anyone bueller all right turn back time
yeah i have no idea
i see that i have been dequeued yeah why
didn't you cue you i forgot
no just because out of it you're just
a whim oh the donkey right yeah it's the
donkey
i still again i'm going to say the
donkey
is it that again that that one wins a
kind of a
you know generic well i do have a few
pork cracklins left so perhaps
well this is a this is not even close
no nick is just all over this nick must
have gotten
bob's the the uh he must have gotten
repository bob's uh
uh gang of what what were you going to
do you were going to get us all
over there i was going to summon some
minions yeah summon some minions
this is he's taking it away does he have
more than everyone else put together i
i i think what's up i'm i'm worried
i'm worried nick
yes it may be like eight seconds left
for somebody to catch up to him but this
looks
daunting and impossible i
a 44 to 22 lead yeah
that's that's dude we got it that's
insane
that's insane kids that's don't try this
at home 21
oh oh 40.
39 oh it's a race against time at this
point the minions are out in full force
yes i am sensing uh overloads on the
servers
right now uh we are being uh we're being
attacked
victorious nick wow man
man excellent well so by the way for the
for the 13 percent of us that voted for
sander
where they maybe we were the only ones
who could see it how about that
uh yeah so what do we got here oh
waiting for the leaderboard
leaderboard we're waiting for the
leaderboard
yes carlo has fallen asleep i'm afraid
total annihilation must have must have
passed out seems like the winning
strategy is to have uh
your name end in a space capital m yes
so far
all right let's go i think six i think
that would work philip that means is
that how you won
that was that's the that's the secret
okay question six is up oh i love this
one
yes yeah yeah and yeah good it does it
does fit
all right so for all poetry
uh generate any kind of structured poem
it doesn't have to make sense but it
does have to follow a poetic form
of some kind um you're not limited to
sonnets and uh right so but uh
you know haikus and limericks are okay
but you're not allowed to use the random
english haiku function how many of you
out there
what if we wrote the random english
and don't use the source code of it
either what if we wrote it
refresh your brain if you i'll tell you
what if you can
rewrite it right now from memory in the
uh
you know you know the judge has spoken
yeah i think i think that we'll we'll
take it if you can rewrite it from
memory
but i challenge anyone to do a limerick
i think that would be really cool
yes yes ricks are hard all and they're
all
filthy is the best part about limericks
um flip do you want to tell them about
uh one other one that's not on your
concrete you call it poetry yeah
concrete poetry so that was
another thought right so if you do a
quick google there are
right there was the whole i don't know
you can go back and look at russian
constructivism
you can look at all these kind of
different movements the goddess
and and that whole movement uh but
concrete poetry is all about graphical
depictions of poetry right so it
involves
fancy typography uh so
uh uh i would uh that i we would
definitely take
uh uh you know good concrete poetry
um right they were typing there were
good they were
like typewriter poetry here's one of my
favorites right
and the the russians they they they knew
how to do this
right so that is that is a concrete poem
um uh i think it's a
this is a pharaoh concrete poem tango
with the cows
so there you go sorry i'm playing uh do
you have uh
so can you share a screen or no with uh
uh we have a submission
oh oh sorry yes i can hold on let me go
and it's it's the incredible robber
mendelsohn yet again
hold on yeah here we go
and i do love that it isn't it's a tone
poem
let's go this is great
right back that we're back to music
again we're back to
tone poems that was robert mendelsohn
yeah
that's beautiful that
that is great what's it called
so it's a it's a way of basically
uh it's a symphonic poem
so it's a it's supposed to
you're supposed to imagine poetry so
it's like concrete poetry
you know where there's some
interpretation between
the execution of the thing and
your interpretation of the thing oh
interesting right i think that if it was
german
it's very german i do believe
rickard strauss and such ricard strauss
and yes that's a good point oh here's
here we go we got another one
i guess you shared the code or do you
want me to share it on my screen i got
it no it's coming
oh the second one requires a huge
download yeah well it's imp
it's importing a uh no the oh
this third one you mean is it the third
invite mike yes
yeah so arith uh gave us
basically this this is again just a
clever use of
uh just a clever use of import
and you know again this is just elegant
and small and quick
and you get a legitimate poem can you
show the the screen
on the screen is it not there no we just
see
oh hold on i'm sorry i'm sorry i was not
i was sharing i'm
my thank you for catching my my
bogus error so now you can see it right
yes all right so there we go so this
just grabs
a piece out of uh poetry db
right and whips out us whips out a
sonnet for you
you know just using import uh import
which i think is pretty clever
it's clever but it doesn't generate yeah
well that's true oh sander
wait a minute
sander sander in the coming from behind
category here
so sander gets the word data
grabs words over length of five it
puts them together in groups good
takes a random sample and then select
pairs oh this is so this is great this
has
so what is this what is this form is it
a form or is it just
sander or is it uh just just for poetry
it's the a b a b c d c d e f
g like the one proposed yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't have the syllables but that's
fine
yeah yeah yeah miley games
i love it this is great this is slow
down bow
monochrome hey by the way i'm uh i'm a
uh i'm a pro anomalous trichromat
in case anyone out there in twitch you
can run it a few times and you get
different ones maybe there's some funny
ones
i'm just happy that muck heap comes up
that was that was what made me happy and
frapp
that's excellent yeah let's run it again
well now it's going oh it's getting the
circus acrobat
probiscus flower brown bat flame thrower
yeah
good close very nice vulcan dioxide
bitter pecan i traded aluminum
i love it this is great
eileen clerk what's wreck-a-pochy clean
and jerk
brilliant phenomenal yeah
this is sandra right oh my god it looks
like it looks like yeah that was sander
it looks like uh
wolverine i mean mine would have been
okay
if you hadn't seen sanders yet now it's
pretty much garbage
i don't know though it's still i just
like again the uh the addition
of oh my gosh so go ahead and
so so there we've taken taken the
resource function
rhymes see there we go clever right
not in the list of disallowed resources
yes that is true it was not
you are correct uh so no that's actually
that one's pretty sweet too
you know it does not have one of these
structures i i i panicked i might be
running out of time
think i think we got our five here let's
uh so carlo has woken up
apparently the uh the uh pint of cream
dements
he was drinking just a moment ago jesse
let's shut it down in like 15. my
colonel hasn't
yeah so by the way so what you're trying
to say is don't run this is that what
you're trying to say
yeah there we go let's see here
yeah this is nice though so again using
so using
uh grabbing the rhymes from phonetic
form
and then using uh
basically using the rhymes to
then right riffling through them
this might yeah i might as well say mine
may not uh this is so confusing
let's come back to this one all right uh
kyle kyle is the most creative one
generated in my head yeah
yeah we'll wait while this uh well the
what we bring this at least i'm not
using the cloud credits
is it will it halt yeah i don't know
this is a touring
can someone look you can send me a bill
for the cloud
okay okay yeah i will i'll make sure
i'll make sure
oh no oh
i'm sorry i'm sorry cannot take
positions one through seven in
a there uh yeah all right
well and then here's uh this one this is
kyle
yeah there once was a rule name 30 seem
more random than qwerty but when it
computed
although it's disputed it looks very
nice
on a surety there you
that's nice okay that's uh that's kyle
yep and then we got one from nick here
all right let's see and i think that's
i think that's it does look nice on the
shirty i have a scarfy with that on
there
so here's nick and again elegant
but going for using the rhymes resource
function which again
we didn't say you couldn't use i don't
know why mine's trying to load it again
but
you know oh that's perfectly legitimate
resource function
yeah and then so let's see here yeah
there you go
healthcare powergen oil of turpentine
nick that rhymes with nine
i get it yeah i get it yeah nick's
challen iraq gate done blink 182
harmonic progression
how did blink 182 get in there is that
it must be
link integer could possibly
all right so i i think we have four let
me tell you who i have you tell me who i
missed yeah let's
let's see what we got here so we got the
tone poem yes that's mendelssohn
i think that's great yeah standard
yeah yeah sanders is just
insane this is i i'm i'm
playing my hand here but this one is a
big winner
yes
and we need the voters to see the death
oh there we go sorry yes
party dabbing pompous hysterics
unfortunately carlos didn't work so we
can't include that
yeah carlo i'm that i love the the
concept is good
it's missing a reverse that's the
problem ah damn it
sort by it's missing a reverse before it
so
oh yeah yeah this right here yeah all
right
yeah if you put the reverse then it's
working
oh can't take positions one through
seven in men's pjs
what that's the point
the error message is the poem
yeah i find myself saying that every
night at that time
actually i'd say we put this in because
yeah when the error message is poetry
that is the best that's the best one
yeah yeah yeah
and then nyx right nick definitely and
then i guess it's a question
who do you like in number five kyle lee
for carlos
i i mean honestly with all due respect
to kyle leaf
i think that the the poetry of
the error message is kind of nice too so
okay
okay so i'm sending that that's just me
that's just my
those are like five i just sent it to
you guys jesse mendelson
sander mr repository total annihilation
and nick merzin
twitch have at it which stupid aardvark
has another
uh one on twitch linricks don't have to
rhyme
oh really huh stupid armor i'm going to
copy it for you into uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but uh so you
can copy it from there but it's uh
he's the master of string concatenation
here we go this is fantastic so while
we're so
so while we're doing it so let's see so
it is a tight race between
sander and oh my goodness it's a horse
race
almost literally a horse race
wow it's really neck and neck oh my
goodness and by the way
we're waiting for this um i sent in the
rocket chat a link on a community post
about rhymes that's super interesting
and everybody should see
there once was okay they're
there once was a man from milan who was
exceedingly rich
he went to the shops and bumped his head
and was never seen again
see this is this is pretty much this is
my idea
right yep this is good who
did this come from this came from
someone on uh stupid aardvark on twitch
oh beautiful stupid aardvark
but nantucket was right there
exactly that's really good there once
was a man from kentucky who was
exceedingly rich he went to spain and
bumped his head yeah so
yeah i think we need to if we run this a
couple million times
yeah this is yeah there we go oh
look at this sander with the seven
percentage point lead
yes going into the final turn going
i feel like i'm back in saratoga can you
check the uh could you check the live
live coding channel in uh rocketjack yes
which one that we have multiple ones
oh it's in the wtc.wolfram.com yeah no
that's that's not me
oh i've been on the wrong one we're
watching it on the side no that's that's
the right one to go
jesse just pointed out that the
submission that you made
was basically the exact same as
a uh i think it was a resource
yeah it just uses the resource but i
changed the seed
i see oh we have a winner oh we do
we sure do we have sander sander edged
this is just with by literally
a hair by a literal hair metaphorical
hair
but we can use the word literally in the
rob low sense
do i need to go to a replay at the
finish line
you know don't don't do a julian isle
philippe and throw those hands up
to earth thinking i'm thinking the one
person difference was probably someone
who discovered the hard way that they
have to uh
listen to the whole thing and there's no
way to quit out of it
all right leaderboard here we go that
was q6 yes
q6 all right q7 we are coming down
look at this we
yes yes and it's still really tight it's
still in here comes question seven
compare it's coming i'm sorry it's not
made it it's not made it
via semaphore flag and boy scout uh
uh here
gonna reload no i'm not gonna reload
because jesse
assures me that the web browser i'm
using
is awesome and i believe correct me if
i'm wrong but this upcoming question 7
is actually the last official question
i do believe you are correct sir unless
we require a tiebreaker
yes so there's still time
for everyone from mike's plural
uh all the way up to to uh
and it's still not showing up here do
the do the contestants have the question
the contestants have it um
okay it's just not showing up on the
leaderboard we can read it
read it for them yeah i'll read it yeah
question seven is to compare
two cities in different counties
states or countries there you go you can
choose
whose names are different but that are
both the same length
as your username sounds like a a
surefire
country music uh system for generating
uh the title of a country music song of
some kind that's michael that's a good
idea
yeah one of them's definitely from
georgia
yes yes the other i guess tennessee
yeah could be and there it'll it'll
involve a dog and a shotgun
at some point we should have you know we
should have done is left
counties just counties but with like a a
gray r
to keep with the ambiguity theme yeah
but in this case uh it's up to the
contestant to decide
how you want to compare how you want to
choose these cities
where they're from and how to compare
them yeah we do have
a little background information about
this question yeah it was originally
written as just
two different countries but somebody
who might be me apparently can't spell
and wrote counties
when we were trying it out we got
suggested answers in two different
counties and we figured
what the hey let's just go with counties
states and honestly you can do different
provinces
it actually made it i'm gonna say it
made the
question better by the way mike uh uh
mike
uh a different gp2 version
output of the poetry thing um it just it
didn't make it through on our
on the the chat framework um
but he sent it to me on rocketchat so
i'll show you guys later okay
okay can you post a sanders solution
it's coming yeah that's what i'm doing
here right now here we go
different planets also acceptable ah
as long as they have named cities i
guess all right so let's see what we got
here so i'm gonna
so the only problem is here there's no
comparison involved right
does it it needs says compare two cities
in different counties or countries yes
he found two which i you know what uh
put an equal sign put equals outside of
that
and that's uh but you can resubmit
sandra no problem yeah yeah
yeah you got time you got time and this
was actually useful for everybody
so we can clarify so you want to find
two cities from wherever
and then somehow compare them whatever
that means
and they have to be the length of a
username
your username yeah yeah uh one yeah but
don't we all have many usernames
so this is pretty good though i i don't
know i know
i know arnhem but i don't know i don't
know almer
i'm probably saying it wrong without
enough in here oh there you go
so so uh
we have oh carlo again has a total of
nine
total annihilation has is bringing the
pain
here there we go
oh he's gonna have a tough time i didn't
realize this is kind of skewed against
him isn't it
it really is how many cities have
whatever that is 48 000 characters
yeah it's gonna be i think that's at
least 30 000 characters right there
i got a better eye than i did yeah no i
don't
could be worse it could be bob's name
this is also true
i have exactly two i'm just coming up
with a good output
well don't forget to compare them yes
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't dream of it
yeah
yeah sander just go ahead and put yeah
you can put same queue
in for in front of sanders right and
then
here's let me fix sanders for him here
there we go the beauty of mathematica i
have now
fixed oops now it's guaranteed to always
be
false right because it's going to get
two different cities
but at least we've compared them but
have we
yes but have we again
so this is car this is my machine is
gonna it's
there's a puddle of plastic and metal
forming here by my desk every time
by the way i wanted to say that i posted
this solution as a form of protest
because this is something that could be
done quite efficiently
server side uh
but it isn't on server side i don't see
now
sander here yeah here's sanders second
submission
while the internet grows to a crawl
uh downloading uh what is it what is it
getting here
it's totally annihilating your computer
yeah it really is this is
this is awesome i'm just now it's
downloading the names
okay before it was just downloading the
canonical oh yeah right right
yeah i have a giga i got a gigabit
connection here this should not be
you know yeah
so sanders that while it's doing this
let's let's look at xander sanders had a
second submission
so all the cities yeah right length name
you took it out two okay and then
it does association oh so okay so a
literal comparison of all of the
properties of each one
right right right right right yeah so we
have one
solution that's same we have sanders
solution
we we sadly
at some point i'm afraid we're gonna
yeah let's see what else
oh here we have it we have some more
uh uh it's taking a while mine's taking
a while i'll put it in a placeholder for
you yeah
okay good good that's good that's uh
yeah i think kyle missed part of the
question as well
wait yeah i'm looking at kyle's and i'm
totally confused
you missed whose names are different
ah nice
canonical names yeah right right right
right kyle good job that you
simplified your name from kyle leaf to
kai leaf
because that sixth thing is pretty cool
yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh and you compared them
that counts
yeah yeah very nice i love it
did we miss somebody or no uh uh oh wait
no
nope fjra address oh well
yes
bob does yours work or is it a is this
one of those
i'm finding out i mean yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's a good
let us know let's let's close the
question in two minutes
yeah so here i'll grab bob's for us here
hey
hey
i don't know jesse you and i we should
look at this oh you had already closed
them
well either either way it's all good
i'll try to simplify it for you
okay and then uh fjra
has a nice answer here hold on uses a
little bit of
geo graphics wait where's nut bottle
uh his he's simplifying it he told me to
wait a second
okay uh fjra got it
yep and then here's
huh i like this
i like where we're going here right so
yeah
yep all right and then you've picked
random cities
and i like this you've given us the
cities as a
uh yeah you you've given us
not only the names of the cities but the
places you've taken it one step further
fjra
and for that for that we
we salute you for those reasons we're in
yes
all right and now here's here's you can
go on without for all the people who are
starting to get hungry at this late hour
this is
the top food image for dallas texas
where i'm based versus uh
salad oh i've spelled it wrong but it's
dallas backwards it's apparently a city
or a district of stockholm
and they apparently eat a lot healthier
there so
so this is a good comparison too right
wait where's the code i'm so confused so
it
all this is this you brute forced this
but where did you get the
where did you get the food from is this
just an output i was gonna say did we
outlaw the um
the use of the uh web web image search
no if it's not if web image search is
the only thing that's kind of not
interesting but
uh this is fine um
i'm confused is this what you fed into
the web image search or no
oh i just searched uh dallas texas food
and then what's it called
uh look to see if there was a city with
the reverse name and apparently there is
yes dallas or salad i i missed
it in my submission oh actually i see
i see all right and then
oh wow so we've uh okay yeah we got to
close this down so uh
adderath gave us a wolfram alpha that is
good
but it's a wolf from alpha okay uh
again doesn't disqualify it or anything
it's just the
here i'll put it in so everyone can see
that you can do this
literally literally with i mean just
just so everybody knows
right uh but you know it'd be nice to
have a little bit of your username
uh length you know to go and
go in there but it is nice though that
you and this is one of the things i love
you know back to our mutual mutual
adoration
uh society for all things yeah clever
and well from language
you know that's definitely one of the
things that's whoops
um is the ability to pull uh
wolfram alpha right into your notebook
that is really cool
this let's see here and this is hp 2000
geographics geopath from champaign
to a random entity the string like i
think that's brilliant
yes yeah because you use the string
length
of your of the name right and so it's a
that's pretty that's pretty awesome it's
not two but i like it because it's even
better
yeah yeah yeah it's fine and then the
last one
is i i like the last daniel martin gave
us
the let's see here
just waiting for my oh nope
his actual username yeah see that that's
why i
and i'm for some reason again it's
probably pilot error here
uh so so he grabbed his username
got the string length grabbed country
data
right and then picked basically two
countries uh and uh uh
got flags with entire times in there
echo at times
but it doesn't matter it looks good yeah
that's perfect and let's see let's see
if let's see if
because i'm not sure what my dollar
username on here this this will be this
will be interesting if it even works oh
yeah
right because right it'll it yeah that's
a great test
yeah all right so i think
i think we got him though so right do we
have our five here
um yes
we have uh sander we have sander the
the the new sander yep kylie
fjra oh this is why it's not working
because i'm
only on 85 500
okay that that one it was a protest
the protest has been disqualified get
back to work
uh this kai leaf very nice i love the i
love the idea of of grabbing
grabbing them and then just sorting them
by uh but
um this one's all right yeah very
elegant
and uh hp 2000 yes hp 2000's
uh which is a generalization really of
uh fgira yes
yeah it is uh and daniel martin yeah
flags at the end
yes and that poll is now live it's live
it's live hold on
last question what a tight race it is it
already
my slang one was supposed to be
now you could see it instead of us
commenting
no one wants to see us people just want
to rock to this
look look look at the finger on them can
you get the lyrics yet
yeah bring up one of those poems i got
the lyrics
once was a man from kentucky
all right oh well what's up
oh by the way we've been it uh the live
coding stream
uh and i how would how would uh uh how
would hakken know that the
word for salad in swedish is salad that
uh this is good we have real authentic
data uh there's some
there's some quality stuff by the way in
the live coding stream
that's that's the uh i'm very impressed
i i yes i yes i figured you were swedish
perhaps you know but i'm never sure
it would be bad to assume we might need
to adjust the twitch votes because
from what i remember mom votes count
double yeah they do mom votes count
double oh kylie
it's all over that's all right that's a
leaderboard
i believe oh my goodness unless we have
it unless we have a tie
this might be a dead coding company it
could be
there might not be we're waiting this is
so exciting
drama this is a drama
oh robert mendelsohn edge is
out nick sander coming in
a solid third and you're the bob
repository now
an honor i bear without a with great
pause and
great sombrity
whoever's in charge of this can we put
all of the contestants
zooms up and we can turn off the screen
share i guess yeah right
i think we can do that now right and uh
can we do like a gallery view is that a
button that's available to
or yeah i don't know who who has who has
controls over the giant levers
oh there's there's mr repositories
on twitch
nick with the shades yeah nice oh i can
only add three to a spotlight
let me and danielle i think you have to
give out the awards
no i don't yes you do
yes i think scott's gonna do that one
oh okay well we're not i'm not giving
out the awards because
surprisingly none of you are sitting in
my living room with me right now
but we will be sending out the rewards
after you know the event is over because
you know that's how we got to do things
nowadays
so can we robert can we please have a
we need we need a word here that's what
we need right now we need
you know how did you do it how did you
prepare no no wait wait wait wait wait
flip flip we have to start from third
place
oh you're right
wait a minute is saying the third again
sander
there he is all right congratulations on
third place
yes sandra what did you do what was your
preparation
what uh you know what how much can you
lift
uh i didn't prepare anything
because it's it was a midnight that this
computation
competition started here you
you and you and carlo having mutual late
night here
nice that was great congratulations yeah
great job on third place
yes and in second place
nick m with the with the stereo glasses
tell us about it nick what have you ha
what have you done what are you drinking
i'm just riding away my sleepiness right
now
because it's also 2 a.m maybe that's an
advantage
yeah well you know good packers late
night right that's a good thing
that's great so is this a first time
were you is this first time you've done
the coding competition
nick did you forget i i won the summer
camp
oh yeah yeah you won the summer that was
a softball question
yes that's right nick is our summer
champion
so this is this is a pretty good there's
a pretty good array
of uh coding champions here uh but
that's right nick one
you know what i couldn't tell with the
shades it's the shades that made it hard
to tell
well congratulations second place and
philip
interview our first place at our first
place
give us some tips the machine mendelbaum
well everyone who's interested should go
to one of our summer programs which are
awesome
i'm not being paid for this plug
explicitly although i'd accept any money
that the wolfram research would like to
send my way
um but uh we have some awesome programs
you'll get some really great learning
there if you haven't checked out
elementary introduction the wolfram
language
it's great and um what's it called even
if you're really good there's a lot of
stuff to be learned there and
we have a great stack exchange um and
you know doing it every day helps quite
a bit as well so uh
the stack exchange the stack exchange is
awesome the reddit
is currently uh full of uh questions
uh about homework so keep that keep the
stack exchange
working place so that the reddit doesn't
turn in yeah anyway
nice awesome congratulations yeah it's
really great let's hear from uh
our other contestants just one at a time
unmute yourselves tell us a bit about
yourself how you doing
where are you going now just to jump in
real quick before the other contestants
get on there yeah
i didn't actually have a chance to say
what they won oh good point
the tesla that is pulling up in your
front yard right now
so for second and third place they will
get
a fifty dollar and twenty five dollar
electronic gift card
respectively first place gets a hundred
dollar gift card
and more importantly they get what's
pictured behind philip
that's right you're getting phillips
house
i mean you're getting your own
championship belt well it's
children you and a tesla to carry the
belt
but we're taking they're getting tesla
that he's going to buy just to give
to you only to take it back in a
flashlight
they call him flip yeah that's that's
the idea but also before we forget let's
thank scott and jesse and dan yes
for the amazing work uh really for
putting everything together and
everything brady and everybody else
it's hard to tell how much is going on
behind the scenes but there's a lot
so thank you all everybody really one of
the best
organized things i am ever associated
with is
is this thing believe it or not so being
here
back to the other people that matter
other contestants yes
so go ahead contestants one at a time
tell us about yourself how are you doing
your thoughts how you doing
are we gonna have to call on people is
this like is this like a zoom class that
i'm teaching i think the teacher needs
to call on the students
yeah i i can speak hi i'm francisco
well i'm from the world front office in
lima
so hello to everybody cool nice awesome
great job today
let's go to uh the crazy horror
carlo hello
i'm sorry about tonight here and i'm
using my ir camera
as any kind of eclectic disease
and i work from the rome
home office and uh
hi very scary i'm glad not to be second
this year
it was just sleeping tonight you did not
take that well
last year that was the you threw the
tape flip the table up it was really
those of you who weren't there it was it
was a it was sad
all right next year the reason is
flickering is because of my rage
radiating right now
phenomenal all right let's go to mr bob
repository yeah
i'm mr bob repository uh nays and
heinrich
uh i work at wolfram i worked on the
function repository and a bunch of other
stuff
and until tonight i was an aspiring
professional live coder but now
i'm going to stick to my day job of
you know not live coding
what do you call that pre-recorded
how long have you been using the wall
from function repository
it's like a a i me a a meeting here well
well the function repository has been
out for about two years
i've been using it a little more than
that
now bob uh mr bob repository what are
the what are the secret tricks to
getting your function accepted besides
being
you oh read the style guidelines
yeah i mean i'd like to be funny but
read the style guidelines there's a
button in the notebook it says style
guidelines push it
read it yeah and it'll save save me a
little bit of time
periods commas do you just do
follow instructions forgot yeah read the
syllabus
and and make sure that you're not doing
something that's already there
yeah the cat has taken over mike
at this point it's probably time for
mike to introduce his cat
i'm afraid oh hi yeah i'm mike i'm a
pilot
um and my cat starbuck he uh
he was coding for me the whole time
although although the last question
is downloading the names of cities in
texas took it was 471 seconds so
by the time you announced the winner i
got the name
so well he got the name so yeah
congratulations
choose a smaller state next time
rhode island from delaware very nice
nice
uh dan ceravolo
okay yes sorry i'm quite sleepy here
it's
2 am so i'll be quick
yeah i'm i'm at my own office here in
italian
yeah i'm in the ball from alpha matte
content team
nice so awesome yeah i i
just learned a lot of stuff about how to
get stuff from repositories and
so on so it was fun but awesome
awesome you're great uh matt
attereth did i say it right yeah thank
you enough
there we go otterath yeah this was super
fun thanks for
for running this i realized that my
obsession with the wolfram challenges
has
made me focus on writing short code and
not
fun impressive code i'll work on that
for next year
awesome well done yeah i've noticed your
name populated all over the leaderboard
of the wolfram challenges
yeah i went a little overboard yeah yeah
that's awesome yeah
that's fantastic um kyle leaf
i mean kyle leaf hi uh
astrophysicist by trade i was just hired
well from a month ago and i'm working
sales
oh goodness so i decided to try this
and as you can tell i can't write good
code but i'd like to think i'm
at least a little funny that was
excellent that was awesome
no there's no such thing as well there
is such a thing as bad code but it's
uh i'm going to be honest uh you know
it's kind of like but
but no there was no bad code tonight
there was no bad code
no bad coat uh did we miss anybody's uh
hakan are you oh yeah khan
i'm a swedish retired developer
a newbie and hobbyist in mathematica and
this is my first
ever live coding competition so it's
i'm very happy for my my single point
how wonderful by the way that's that's
infinitely more points
than philip and i have right now so
that's
so i think that's you should that's very
good yeah awesome thanks
uh did we miss anybody uh luigi luigi
yeah
or did luigi luigi disappeared i guess
it's too late for luigi um did we miss
anybody else
all right jesse wrap it up for us what's
your insights
yeah he is the man behind everything
everything not just in the
coded competition not just at the tech
conference not just that wolfram but the
entire world
he's like the architect of the matrix so
jesse we we need some advice if you say
so yes
i'm i'm i'm jesse i'm currently i'm in
my home office
in geosynchronous orbit uh 35 000
kilometers above the indian ocean
um and that was my joke that's all i got
sorry yeah
right but you'd but it looks like you
shaved since we last saw you so the
no that's an illusion oh it's an optical
illusion
awesome and last question is for twitch
did anybody come up with the magic trick
yes exactly
go ahead oh by the way uh bob
bob resource sent a gift to
uh uh to the other to
to mendelssohn here so there you go
there's a
yeah that's awesome
so it's awesome that there is a cloud
resource function
well that's deployed to my cloud account
with my api key with with your raso
but it was a free api key so yeah
everyone on the live stream uses it
giphy will shut it down yeah exactly
yeah yeah everybody great job today and
uh
you know what's most amazing to me is
how many cool things can be done in so
many different ways and such a little
amount of code
in a very brief amount of time right any
one of these things could have been
three four
six-month projects and you all came up
with solutions in five minutes so
wonderful wonderful congratulations to
everybody
thank you all for a wonderful time and
thanks
big thanks to flip and phillip for
hosting this event yet again
you are both fantastic and wonderful and
kept us
all laughing all evening so thank you
thank you thank you you can't hear the
round of applause but it is happening
i can see it
all right i think we are going to call
this an evening thanks so much everyone
all right peace out flip yeah thanks
everybody